good evening everyone I'm going to go
ahead and get started thank you for
coming tonight and welcome to Columbia
University Library my name is Shawn
Quimby i'm the director of the rare book
and manuscript library and we're here
tonight for a conversation between Larry
tie and a Jack Rosenthal that both marks
and celebrates the publication of the
book and the new book by Larry tie Bobby
Kennedy the making of a liberal icon and
also to to mark Larry's decision to
place the research file that you
compiled in the course of writing the
book with the rare Book and Manuscript
library so so to at least two things
we're celebrating probably more so
before I introduce the speakers I want
to be certain to invite you to a
post-event reception and book signing in
the Rare Book and Manuscript library
kempner gallery which is upstairs on the
sixth floor you can take the elevator or
the stairs if you're feeling energetic
after after the event probably about 7
30 we'll head upstairs and then while
you're sipping wine and waiting to have
your book signed you can also look at
our two exhibitions the first one is the
Pulitzer Prizes from Julia Ward Howe to
Hamilton a selective look at a hundred
years of excellence and the other one in
our smaller gallery is Ellery Queens
mystery magazine 75th anniversary I'm
guessing that at least one of those will
be of interest to the audience tonight
alright so 52 years ago this month a
candidate for US Senate robert f kennedy
visited the campus of columbia
university to field questions from
thoughtful and tough minded students why
run in new york instead of massachusetts
how do you explain your support of the
red-baiting Senator Joe McCarthy when
will you issue a definitive statement on
civil rights and what will it say at
first Kennedy seemed a bit testy
equipping that if the length of resident
he was the most important qualification
for Senate why not vote for the oldest
man in New York but then he grew more
relaxed and as the half hour session war
on studying statistics on poverty
education and echoing his older brother
he challenged the audience to do its
part to address these areas of concern
he then exited the stage to a den of
enthusiastic applause this is available
on youtube if you're wondering how I
know all of this tonight's guest Larry
Thai asks many of those same questions
in his best-selling book Bobby Kennedy
the making of a liberal icon released
last July the book has received
widespread acclaim including two reviews
in The New York Times in one of the
reviews historian David Nassau credits
ty for reconciling the to Bobby problem
that is a fervent cold warrior and then
left wing anti-vietnam hero by quote
presenting us with a kind of
bildungsroman of a young privileged man
who is forced to learn the job learn on
the job and makes mistakes of a rich
man's son who was thrown into positions
he's ill qualified for in another review
critic Michiko Kakutani writes quote mr.
Tai conscientiously strips away the
accretions of myth that have come to
surround robert f kennedy while at the
same time creating a sympathetic
portrait of this complex and searching
man a genuine pilgrim and hard-nosed
politician a fierce romantic dedicated
to the art of the possible and so Larry
ties made a career of writing about
heroes from satchel paige to superman
and now to bobby kennedy his first book
the father of spin considers the life of
edward bernays in the birth of public
relations it would seem that larry has a
particular knack from d mythologizing
subjects while also humanizing them a
journalist by training and occupation ty
spent 15 years as an award-winning
investigative reporter with the Boston
Globe and other newspapers and he brings
the doggedness of the beat reporter to
his book projects and for that we at
Columbia are especially grateful the
interview tapes that he will be placing
with us in the rare book and manuscript
library contained store
very few people have had the chance to
hear and that I suspect are the result
of this same doggedness all right since
the publication of Bobby Kennedy Ty's
been featured on NPR's fresh air and
MSNBC's Morning Joe he's given lectures
and signed a lot of books and hopefully
will be signing a few more tonight what
sets this event apart from those that
have preceded it is that he'll be in
conversation with Jack Rosenthal who
served as a special assistant to rock
Bobby Kennedy during his time as
attorney general from nineteen sixty one
to nineteen sixty-four Rosenthal's
accomplished career has taken him from
the position of copy boy at the portland
oregon ian to multiple roles with the
new york times where he won a pulitzer
prize for distinguished
editorial-writing in 1982 at the times
he served as editor of The Times
Magazine from nineteen ninety three to
two thousand and wrote the on language
column for 27 years maybe at the
cocktail party we can talk about William
Safire who I worked closely with in when
i was in my previous position at
syracuse jack has held senior positions
in the State Department academia and
philanthropy he's the president emeritus
of the new york times company foundation
in the founding chairman of reserve a
nonprofit that connects skilled older
adults with service agencies in New York
and five other cities his career has
embodied the same drive and commitment
to service that Bobby Kennedy invoked in
his speech to Columbia University
students some 52 years ago and so with
that I'm going to turn things over to
our guests Jack Rosenthal in Larry tie
please welcome them
thank you all let me begin with a trivia
question what do the following have in
common mental health baseball propaganda
comic book heroes civil rights and
American politics somebody's brilliant
answer exactly right Larry time we're
lucky to be here and to have Larry here
to talk about an extraordinary book
before we get deep into the book though
I'd like to play off a current events
and ask Larry about Robert Kennedy's one
of his most famous speeches was not done
by speechwriter it was impromptu was on
the night of April fourth 1968 he was
outside in a public square in
Indianapolis on the night that Martin
Luther King was killed and riots went on
in several cities who was a touching
speech which kept among other things
kept Indianapolis quiet that night and I
questioned Valeri is there a lesson or a
moral in his capacity to reach not just
blue-collar whites but also blacks and
intellectual heights in a way that we do
not now see in this country yes
so I'd love to just tell a quick story
about that speech to set a stage and me
for those of you who don't know what
that speech was about this was in the
middle of the 1968 campaign when Bobby
Kennedy started out in that campaign
jumping into the race four days after
New Hampshire primary after gene
McCarthy had showed how vulnerable
Lyndon Johnson was by when you added up
the Democratic votes and the Republican
right ends beating him in the New
Hampshire primary and he started off
looking opportunistic and ruthless and
that was what the press thought the
Murray Kempton the famous columnist
wrote a telegram at that time to Ted
Kennedy saying that your brother's entry
into this presidential race shows that
st. Patrick didn't drive all the snakes
out of Ireland and that was what
reporters and that was with the public
thought of Bobby Kennedy's starting out
in that 68 campaign if we flash forward
to the night you asked about in
Indianapolis Bobby Kennedy was
contesting his first primary in the
state of Indiana he was running against
gene McCarthy and a very formidable
favorite son named governor Brannigan
who when he was sober was an incredible
candidate and Bobby is running against
the two of them he flies in this night
in April to Indianapolis he's greeted at
the airport by the young mayor of
Indianapolis a guy who would go on to
become an old senator named Richard
Luger and Luger says to Bobby I've got
horrible news for you Martin Luther King
has been shot and killed and he says you
will not go tonight and deliver the
speech you would plan to give in the
middle of the black ghetto you won't go
because you might not come out alive and
because there will be a riot there Bobby
politely listen to Luger and proceeded
to go drive into the ghetto and he
jumped up on the back of a flatbed truck
when he got there and he delivered for
the next five minutes what might have
been the singly most pitch perfect
speech that a white politician has ever
delivered in black America and I want to
read you
I didn't know you're gonna ask that
question but I carry this in my pocket
everywhere I go and I want to read you a
few lines from that speech and I'm gonna
not I'm going to try to do it straight
and not try to give you a Bobby Kennedy
accent because I couldn't do that anyway
even though I'm from Boston and Bobby
said I'm not going to talk to you I'm
only going to talk to you for a minute
or so this evening because I have some
very sad news for all of you Martin
Luther King was shot and killed tonight
and I want to stop for a second and say
that if you turn on YouTube you can hear
that speech and you will hear at that
moment in that speech people in the
audience going oh no and that can't be
most of the 300 people there were in the
ghetto that night we're hearing for the
first time that Martin Luther King had
been killed from Bobby Kennedy and he
continues in a louder voice he says for
those of you who are black and are
tempted to be filled with hatred and
mistrust of the injustice of such an act
against all white people I would only
say that I can feel in my own heart the
same kind of feeling I had a member of
my family killed but he was killed by
white man I don't I want to stop for
another second and just say that in the
five years from Jack Kennedy's death in
1963 to this night in 1968 Bobby Kennedy
had never talked publicly about the loss
of his brother and even that night he
couldn't manage to bring himself to say
either the word jack or brother it was
just a member of my family and he
continued what we need in the United
States is not hatred what we need in the
United States is not violence and
lawlessness but is love and wisdom and
compassion toward one another and a
feeling of justice towards those who
still suffer within our country whether
they be white or whether they be black
so I ask you tonight to return home to
say a prayer for the family of Martin
Luther King yeah it's true but more
importantly to say a prayer for our own
country which all of us love a prayer
for understanding
and that compassion of which I spoke now
to get to your question I think
something miraculous happened that night
in the ghetto Bobby Kennedy went into
the black community to embrace them for
the loss of his for the loss of Martin
Luther King their revered leader and
instead that community embraced him for
the last five years before of his
brother Jack that night in America as
you suggested in more than a hundred
cities there were race riots my guess is
those of you who were older old enough
remember what happened that night in
Washington a big chunk of the city was
burned down in Chicago there were
burnings and a big piece of the city was
set on fire there were only a couple
cities and only one really that mattered
that had sizable black populations that
didn't riot that night and that city of
course was Indianapolis and the reason
was robert francis kennedy i can say
without hyperbole and you should never
trust a journalist who tells you they're
going to say anything without hyperbole
but this really is true from that moment
till the end of that campaign in the end
of his life bobby kennedy was a singly
most popular white man in black America
from that moment any time he campaigned
in a black ghetto a sign would turn up
somewhere in the audience that said very
simply white but all right now that may
not sound like much but in 1968 four
people in the black community to say
that about any white politician was
saying a lot so to answer your question
this is precisely the tone that we need
today in America this is the tone that
that Barack Obama has been striving to
find these are the words that Hillary
Clinton has been striving to find I
won't in any attempt to show equal time
suggest that Donald Trump has been
striving but i will say that nobody
barack obama came the closest in the
45-minute speech he delivered at the
funeral of the Dallas police officers
and even in his 45-minute talk he didn't
come close to the five minute ad lib
speech the Bobby Kennedy gave that night
so he was on the cusp of doing something
magical in terms of earning the trust of
America generally and in terms of
disenfranchised minorities in america in
1968 and I say this not as a matter of
nostalgia even though we all get
nostalgic and talking about it but as a
matter of what we ought to hold our
politicians today to as a standard of
how they have to try to reconcile
warring parts of the American electorate
it's a wonderful answer and it leads me
directly to another question a big
reason that I so admire Larry's book is
because he resists the temptation to
fall into the good Bobby bad Bobby trap
the Manichaeans suggestion that until a
certain point maybe his brother's
assassination that he was a hard-nosed
right-wing ruthless Bobby David
Halberstam wrote that way Reynold Ronald
steel wrote that way why did they do
that my own thought is it simply
reflected their ignorance of the early
Bobby's complexities for example the I
think the first day or first week he
became Attorney General as busy as that
was he took time out to help dedicate
his children's playground and black
Washington in his first year he
appointed something called the Allen
committee of leading lawyers and judges
from around the country trying to create
a better system of criminal justice he
had the devotion of his staff at justice
for from the first day Harold Reese who
was then his special assistant told the
story of coming to work on
watched presidents presidents birthday
holiday and bobby was so impressed by
the number of cars that he saw in the
garage down in the basement of the
Justice Department that he asked
somebody to get the license numbers and
he wrote little notes to all the people
who had come into work that day
including to Harold Reese and Harold
sort of sheep lessly said well it's
being Washington's Birthday I cannot
tell a lie I was parked there because my
wife wanted me to go shopping with her
the thing that I so admire about Larry's
book can be summarized let me read a
quote from it he said the Odyssey he had
been through the painful deaths of three
siblings the loss of his father's
guiding hand crises over Cuban missiles
and campus race riots brought to the
surface his sense of irony and empathy
it happened not in a single
transformative moment but in subtle
incremental stages Larry could you talk
about when that began sure so it begin
at the very beginning and I think the M
can we go back for a minute to the
McCarthy era true and so Bobby anybody
here go to the University of Virginia by
the way great so I can say anything I
want about then so Bobby graduated from
law school at the University of Virginia
because he hadn't gotten into Harvard
Law School and he finished smack in the
middle of his class there and the when
he was looking for his first serious job
when he got out of law school he did
what he always did he did it partly out
of what he wanted to do and partly out
of what his father thought that he
should be doing and he went to work for
his father's Joseph P Kennedy's great
buddy Joe McCarthy and he went to work
for him because Bobby believed in that
stage of his life that Joe McCarthy was
the one guy in Washington who took
seriously the Soviet threat and not just
the Soviet threat in the Soviet Union
but what much of America thought was a
threat in our own government behind
every pillar in the State Department and
Bobby Kennedy stayed there for seven and
a half months he was not just the young
staffer for John McCarthy Joe McCarthy
would come home at night with Bobby and
Ethel at times and play with young
Kathleen who was a toddler then and he
adored Joe McCarthy and and what I
respect about Bobby from that era is not
his judgment on McCarthy because I think
he ought to have had better judgment and
those even those early days about
McCarthy I respect the fact that he
never hit it and he never hid the fact
that he went to Joe McCarthy's funeral
when Jack Kennedy had told him you ought
to stay away from there and Joe McCarthy
was his friend and he was going to be
loyal and he was going to show up at Joe
McCarthy's funeral but in terms of the
question that you asked then the nuance
and nothing was ever as simple as his
being just the McCarthyite Bobby Kennedy
wrote the minority Democratic report on
the army McCarthy hearings that ended up
being adopted it was such an impressive
report that the Republican majority in
the Senate adopted that most of it as
their report that centered Joe McCarthy
so Bobby Kennedy in the one hand was the
loyal body and didn't see all of
McCarthy's flaws and yet he helped bring
down his pal Joe McCarthy because he was
an honest guy and went where the facts
took him and I think at every point in
his life if you look at something good
you can see hidden in it something bad
and if you look at something bad you
could see hidden in it that there was
some good somewhere and he was an
incredibly complicated nuanced character
and I want to just say that I started
out writing this book with Bobby Kennedy
as my hero his famous quotes were up on
my wall in high school and I went to
high school with Bobby Kennedy's most
troubled middle child David who was the
one who years later would die of a drug
overdose and i started with him as my
hero i saw in the course of writing the
book a lot of bad things about Bobby
Kennedy from some of his Joe McCarthy
stuff to some of his fetching his real
role in
and Missile Crisis two other things that
had done there weren't noble things and
by the time I got done writing the book
he was more of a hero than he had
started as because to me a hero is a
flesh-and-blood hero and somebody with
strengths and weaknesses and what
matters with a hero is where they end up
and I think Bobby Kennedy by 1968 had
learned from his own mistakes would have
judged many things in his past more
harshly than any biographer would ever
have done and ended up in a place that
is not just historically interesting but
offers us a model today and if I can be
long winded and I promise I won't meet
as long with every question that you ask
but I want to just say a moment for a
moment who Bobby Kennedy was at the time
of his death in 1968 in 2016 terms Bobby
Kennedy was uniting angry white Donald
Trump supporters who were his supporters
going back to his Joe McCarthy days
there were people that we would later
call Reagan Democrats and he was uniting
them with Hillary Clinton's coalition of
liberals and minorities and he was on
the cusp of putting together a coalition
that 50 years later many of us dream
about happening today and so as I say
this isn't a matter of nostalgia and
looking back and saying this is horrible
that Bobby Kennedy's not with us it is a
matter of looking and saying we can put
together that same coalition today and
why aren't we doing it let me switch
gears a little bit and save my own
personal knowledge that Ethel Kennedy
was extremely reluctant ever to let
anybody see the rfk papers and extremely
reluctant to ever talk to a biographer
the probably a half a block full of
Kennedy papers boxed which you wouldn't
ever let anybody see along comes Larry
tie and somehow charms her to the extent
he could say things like on page well I
can't find it at the moment but it's she
quoted pillow talk with RFK Larry how
did you charm her so much right so the
great sir I would love to tell you that
I'm so charming and I was irresistible
and she had to talk to me the truth is
that she just turned eighty eight and
I'm a guy who came at the moment that
she was sensing her own mortality and I
was the one on the doorstep so it was
either me or nobody and she was
wonderful and I got to tell you just two
quick things about talking to Ethel one
is I live more than half the year i live
on Cape Cod and I live in a place that's
about 10 minutes from where fo lives in
Hyannis Port but when I talked to her of
course it would have been too simple to
say come on over to hyannis board she
said fly to Palm Beach and we'll talk
and the and I fly to Palm Beach and I'm
totally convinced given Ethel's
reluctance to ever talk to the press she
she was reluctant to talk to her own
daughter for a wonderful film that her
daughter made called Ethel and all of
her sentences in that film were three
words and she didn't want to be talking
and I think that she doesn't like to she
doesn't especially trust journalist or
office so I was convinced I had 15
minutes and she'd send me packing and
that i had to front-load all my
questions and so in the first 15 minutes
i asked everything that was critical and
two hours later Ethel was offering she
was going on in her bare feet to her
driveway and saying I want to give you a
ride to the airport and make you a
sandwich now I had read enough about
Ethel's cooking and about her driving
that I politely thanked her and so I
have my own car and I'm gonna get
something on the plane but the she was
extraordinary and while she was hesitant
I don't think I could have written this
book or written it with any confidence
without talking to her because what she
let me do was run by her every theory i
had on Bobby Kennedy and she knew Bobby
Kennedy i interviewed the children i
interviewed lots of people who knew him
in different contact
but nobody in the Kennedy family was
ever the kind of equal partner partners
that Ethel and Bobby were and she let me
test out the theory of Joe McCarthy I'd
spent time with her wonderful children
who told me that Joe McCarthy was a
footnote or an aberration in the Bobby
Kennedy story so don't pay much
attention to Joe McCarthy and Ethel said
that was garbage that they had an
extraordinary relationship that America
may have thought of Joe McCarthy is
being a monster but to them he was the
guy who came over and played as I said
with toddler Kathleen who they had
dinner with that he was a charming guy
and to understand Joe McCarthy knowing
that piece of him that he could like
Donald Trump in certain contexts be
incredibly charming is an important
piece of who he was and how he made the
success that he made of his career as a
demagogue and she did the same thing
about the relationship between Jack and
Bobby the cliche was that they would
finish run on other sentences she said
that that wasn't true that they didn't
have to even talk that they just watched
one another's body language and they got
who the other one was in that particular
circumstance and it was the kind of
communication we use again a phrase
today of co presidency in will Hillary
Clinton make cane her co-president
because they're so close well the truth
is that no president ever gives up half
of their power to anybody their vice
president or anybody else but the
closest thing America I think has ever
had to a co presidency with Jack and
Bobby because whether was domestic
affairs or the missile crisis of the Bay
of Pigs bobby was there on everything
that mattered to Jack and Ethel helped
me see that in a hundred other things so
her two words were enough she would say
yes or no when I had a theory that was
right or wrong and she helped me throw
away the wrong ones or at least go back
and study those again and she was
wonderful one would think from Larry's
accounts of pillow talk and other
positive things that Ethel said about
her late husband that this book is
something about hagiography
not so it's an honest bill connacher
give you an example in discussing our F
K's book about the Cuban Missile Crisis
13 days here's what Larry wrote his
story is laced with fictions a
fundamentally self-serving account that
casts him as the champion he would like
to have been rather than the unrelenting
hawk he actually was through much of
those two weeks Laurie do you want to
say more about those two weeks so I want
to say two things I'm going to try to be
more concise and the one is so I always
wondered how we got into the Cuban
Missile Crisis and I thought the story
that I had grown up with was that this
evil guy who ran the Soviet Union named
Nikita Khrushchev out of whim or out of
just trying to exercise his muscle put a
bunch of missiles in Cuba and that was a
horrible threat and we went in and we
stood eyeball to eyeball with him and
stare down our enemy the truth I think
is that we got into the Cuban Missile
Crisis we know because of all the papers
that have become public is that for a
year before the cuban missile crisis in
the wake of the Bay of Pigs the Kennedys
were upset enough about Fidel Castro and
what he was doing and the way he had
embarrassed them at the Bay of Pigs that
we conducted a secret war that was known
by its code named Operation Mongoose
trying to upset the Cuban government
trying to and displace if not
assassinate Fidel Castro and that Nikita
Khrushchev decided with a lot of
justification that the way to protect
the cubanita Cuba needed protecting and
the way to do that was to put missiles
in Cuba and so he went ahead and did
that and so Bobby Kennedy I think in a
substantial way helped get us into the
cuban missile crisis during the early
days of the crisis Bobby Kennedy while
he would later describe himself as
having been a dub throughout he was a
hawk he wanted to attack Cuba to go bomb
them and he thought that we needed a
decisive and a strong military response
it was only part way through the crisis
that he turned to the idea of a blockade
and became his brother Jack's best ally
in pushing for blockade judging from
Bobby Kennedy's book the hero of the
crisis was Bobby the real hero of the
crisis i think was Jack Kennedy the
crazy thing and the thing that I could
never figure out is why Bobby spun the
truth the way he did when he knew better
than anybody that he and Jack had been
taping the Cabinet Room conversations
and that someday they would become
public and today they are public and we
can go in and see Bobby's true role it
didn't take a great investigative
reporter to figure out what Bobby's
worldwide it just took listening to the
tapes of his conversation and I think
that that was one of many times that
Bobby showed that he was not only an
incredibly empathetic character and
heroic in many circumstances but he was
one of the world's great spin Meister's
let me add a couple of Columbia related
footnotes to that story one of them my
friend Max Frankel a long time heroic
figure at the New York Times was at at
time of the missile crisis The Times
correspondent in Moscow and he wrote a
letter at the Times in response to
review of Larry's book in which he
begged to correct the record that the
reason Khrushchev sent missiles to Cuba
was not out of malevolence and not out
of a desire to so much to support Castro
but out of knowledge that the United
States was spending enormous songs to
build intercontinental missiles and he
couldn't afford to match those he had
intermediate range missiles but not
intercontinental range so he wanted to
send them to Cuba to offset the American
advantage in big missiles the second
Columbia footnote is and this has only
been recently been uncovered
is Bobby and Jack Kennedy weren't sure
that their dealings with Khrushchev were
going to succeed the deal that they had
proposed to him was they would if he
would turn the missiles around they
would remove a series of obsolete
Jupiter missiles that were in Turkey
near Russia if he would keep that secret
which in fact he did didn't become known
publicly for 25 years but as a
demonstration of statecraft they weren't
sure that Khrushchev would accept that
so they went to Andrew Cormier who was
then the Provost here at Columbia and
got him to agree to go talk to the
secretary-general of the United Nations
and ask him to propose a deal public
deal to the United States and to Russia
to get the missiles out of Turkey in
exchange for Khrushchev getting the
missiles out of Cuba that way the
Americans the Kennedys would not be
blamed for being weak anyway the burden
would fall on the UN for trying to prove
provide peace
there's another aspect to rfk and the
president's and it's called Lyndon
Johnson there are probably a bookshelf
worth of accounts of their relationship
and I wonder Larry if you might talk
about it from the beginning when he was
sitting at a table in the I guess in the
Senate dining room and LBJ came by and
kind of smirked at him so just as a
preface to that i want to say they were
in his life there were four people that
Bobby Kennedy truly despised and I think
that them he had pretty good judgment in
the first three one of them was the FBI
director J Edgar Hoover who any person
in their right mind and especially any
person in the White House would have
come to despise a second one was the
leader of the Teamsters Union that Bobby
thought was corrupt named Jimmy Hoffa
the third one was somebody that we've
just found a new reason to despise long
after his death the guy named Roy Cohn
who was a young aide to Joe McCarthy and
an old tutor to a young Donald Trump all
of them it made sense to me the tragic
fourth one that Bobby maybe hated more
than any of those other three was Lyndon
Johnson and the story that Robert Cairo
tells brilliantly in his biography his
latest volume of his biography of Lyndon
Johnson is that a young Bobby Kennedy
Senate staffer is sitting at a table
with Joe McCarthy and the cafeteria at
the Senate dining room and an older
Lyndon Johnson comes in and and they are
the first time they cite one another
they were like two dogs with a hair
standing in the back of their head that
there was just something instinctual
that they sense that they weren't going
to like about the other one and I think
over the years there are a million
reasons that people have speculated why
I think it was that they just came from
such different worlds that Bobby Kennedy
was the world that and I'm not going to
say this with a proper accent but the
Hamid's
that LBJ so hated and they represented
everything wrong they represented
elitism they represented money they
represented all the things that Bobby
Kennedy in truth was a part of his
background and LBJ couldn't tolerate
that that Bobby couldn't tolerate the
fact that LBJ was crude was from East
Texas and East Texas community college
and was just not the kind of guy that he
especially wanted around him and
certainly not the kind of guy that he
wanted his brother to have as his vice
president and yet all the stories or a
million stories about how Bobby tried to
sabotage Jack's naming LBJ is the vice
president and I think all those stories
are things that Bobby in a way he'll
plant later on to make it look like he
was even more opposed because the fact
is he would never have gone up against
Jack on something that vital and more
importantly he would never have gone up
against Jack on something as essential
to Jack's being elected president having
a powerful senator from Texas who could
help carry the South who could help
carry Texas on the ticket was
instrumental to Jack winning and Bobby
wanted nothing in the world more than
Jack being president he also understood
that instrumental to the Kennedys
getting their program through the Senate
was having a weaker Senate Majority
Leader a guy like Mike Mansfield rather
than a guy like Lyndon Johnson who would
have had a separate power base so the
perfect way to get a guy on the ticket
who would help the ticket was to pick
jaha pick lyndon johnson and the perfect
way to defang lyndon johnson was to take
him from a powerful position like senate
majority leader and put him in a
powerless position like vice president
and the horror to bobby was the three
years later LBJ would end up in the
White House and but I want to say one
more thing about that can I borrow your
head for a second ok so when everybody
remembers what happened in November of
1963 and suddenly we go from having this
young president who was promising us new
frontiers ahead to having a 200 year old
guy named Lyndon Johnson who nobody
especially wanted to be in the White
House suddenly in the Oval Office and I
want to borrow your head because what
Bobby Kennedy I think did for Lyndon
Johnson is he symbolically laid
hands on him and he said even though he
despised him gave him a sense of
legitimacy there was nobody who could
give legitimacy the way that Jack's
younger brother could do and he showed
up at his first cabinet meeting with
great pain he did things to say to the
country that this guy is our new
president and whether we like him or not
we've gotta rally behind him and I think
that meant a lot and I think LBJ never
gave him credit for that and they to
meet one of the great tragedies in
American politics of the 1960's is to
imagine what could have happened if you
had Washington's two most passionate
advocates for civil rights for ending
poverty if they had come together and
been a coalition rather than hating one
another and we might have even gotten
out of Vietnam earlier because Bobby
Kennedy with good reason was convinced
that every time he called for a bombing
halt it made LBJ step up the bombing and
that we ended up there longer because
LBJ wasn't about to back down with Bobby
well and there's a ps2 that called Nixon
let me tell a personal story about that
I was a 26 year old jr. while i was
called assistant director of public
information which was a highly inflated
way of describing the number two man in
a two-man office and i spent a lot of
the time answering the phone from and
you can guess RFK got lots of press
calls every day I probably did 50 a day
and then spent some time writing
speeches and testimony on Tuesday
November 26th 1963 after the kennedy
funeral Bobby who nobody had seen since
the assassination I came to work that
morning my office was across the hall
from his and as I nearing my office I
saw him in shirtsleeves duck across the
hall into my boss's office at Gutman's
office and I thought oh what a relief I
didn't have to greet him
girl had not a clue as to what to say
when in my room sat down the phone rings
it's ed calling from his office said
would I come in so I go in and there's
Kennedy sprawled across two chairs in
his shirtsleeves looking gray and add
says have you seen this and he holds up
the wall street journal in the middle
front page is a story about what the
Kennedy men think of their new president
and high in the story is a quote from
high Justice Department official saying
the thing that bothers me is his
wheeler-dealer mentality and and this is
obviously caused kennedys and grief or
they're both nervous about it and it
says well you know Jody Matheson The
Wall Street Journal reporter could you
ask him who the high Justice Department
official was I of course you're not
going to get any reporter to tell you
their source but in that circumstance
alike I'll try so I go back to my room
and I call Jody and he said it's
interesting you call me because I was
about to call you why and he said well I
don't really know how to say this to you
but the source was you
with me what are you talking about so
well you know when we talked yesterday
morning how we talked about LBJ and
Kennedy and I said I said nothing like
that and I remember clearly what I said
I said I really admired Johnson because
he had been so deferential to Kennedy as
vice president and also because he's
been so sincere about civil rights in
fact you just made a brilliant civil
rights speech in Philadelphia and I said
the only thing you bothered me was as
cat kick personality and Jody
said well a little later in the day a
circular memo went around to the bureau
and reporters were asked to answer the
question what do the Kennedy people on
your beats think of their new president
and he said night gave him that quote
but bud Carmen who wrote the story knew
he couldn't get kick into the paper
so he changed it two wheeler dealer
isn't it that about the same thing well
no it's not fix it but i still had i had
a problem what was I going to do was I
going to walk back into that room with
that broken man and I was going to say
it was me well I tried to think of any
way out of it I couldn't so I finally
went in and I said it was me and he
jumped up and he said thank God it was
just some schmuck in the press office he
thought it was an assistant attorney
general who Johnson would find out about
it would mean something I told the story
to Bob Cairo and he answered he he asked
a really smart question which you
probably were asking yourself why did
Kennedy care so much and the only
plausible answer is because he still
entertained the possibility of forcing
himself as Johnson's vice presidential
candidate in the 64 campaign
um
there's a wonderful quote in in Larry's
book which he applause Jules Feiffer who
called his schizophrenic senator the
bobby twins explaining that the good
Bobby sent federal troops down south to
enforce civil rights the bad Bobby
appointed racist judges down south to
enforce civil rights the good Bobby is
gilded ease with liberals the bad Bobby
is ill at ease with grownups we'll see
more about that sure so I think I want
to actually before I say that they were
in a wonderful research library and I
want to just say one quick word of
acknowledgment to one so anytime you
write a biography especially if you're
writing 110 thigh ography written on
somebody and you're standing on a lot of
earlier works and you get to know which
of the earlier works are okay to stand
on and what's you're likely to fall down
if you stand on for too long and the
best the thickest and the best of the
early biographies was written by a guy
named Arthur Schlesinger who had written
a wonderful biography on President
Kennedy and number one and Bobby and I
just wanted to say that Arthur's son
steve is here and steve was incredibly
generous instead of helping me
understand Arthur's papers and
understand the work his dad had gone
through Andy and in terms of the good
Bobby in the bad Bobby I think it was
really interesting that the guy who
captured in a way Bobby best was not any
of the two million political reporters
who were out there following him around
everywhere that it was a really
brilliant cartoonist who thankfully for
me was still alive 50 years later to ask
what he thought about the good Bobby and
bam Bobby and I want to tell you what he
said about it so he stood by everything
he wrote then but he said Jules Feiffer
you all know Jules Feiffer on all the
great books as well it's great cartoons
he's written over the years and you
probably also know that he
on Martha's Vineyard and he said it was
impossible for years after he wrote that
good Bobby bad Bobby to the occasion on
Martha's Vineyard because there was so
many Kennedy buddies there and they gave
him such an extraordinarily hard time
that he couldn't show up in the beach
for a long time but i think that the but
i think he captured it right it was
never that bobby was as we talked about
in starting out he was a nuanced
character and there was always both good
and bad and just about everything he did
and yet the idea of capturing it in a
short cartoon the way he did was in a
way the best way to look at Bobby
Kennedy Bobby Kennedy had more ink
devoted to him in the years when he was
Attorney General but more importantly in
his years as a senator when he was
called the government in exile and he
was called the heir apparent and he was
called every name suggesting that he was
about to run for the presidency and I
think that then it was partly torture to
him because he really wasn't ready to
run he wasn't ready to run even in 1968
when he did run and he sure as heck
wasn't ready to run when he was a u.s.
senator and it was torture to Lyndon
Johnson because Lyndon Johnson Lyndon
Johnson's nightmare I'm convinced was
that his political biography would be
essentially bookended by two Kennedys
and that he would be this little what
was the peanut butter in the sandwich
and that he would done and that was his
paranoia and when Bobby ended up the
clearing it was even more as paranoia
and when Bobby ended up forcing him out
of the race so when he felt like he had
to leave the race in the middle of that
campaign it was a nightmare for him and
I think that that I'm convinced so you
didn't ask me this question I'm going to
try to answer it anyway that I think
what would have happened in 1968 had
Bobby Kennedy lived is anybody remember
the last public words that Bobby Kennedy
said in that famous speech his victory
speech in California before he left the
podium remember what his last words were
no
sit say it one more time line and we're
on to Chicago and B and what he meant
was the next day he was due to go to
Chicago and he was due to meet with
Mayor Richard Daley and fifty years
later Richard dailies and son Bill
Bailey who was for a short time Obama
nuts a short time was Obama's chief of
staff Bill Daley says that his dad
almost certainly was going to endorse
Bobby Kennedy the next day in Chicago
and everybody I talked to from that era
anybody who was either covering politics
or who was a politician said if the
single most powerful member of the
democratic political establishment had
endorsed Bobby it would have set off a
ground swell of other endorsements and
you will recall that Hubert Humphrey
entered not a single primary and one not
one vote and I'm convinced that at the
Chicago Convention because this is what
Democrats did back then they would have
nominated Bobby Kennedy and Hubert
Humphrey despite Lyndon Johnson's
protestations or maybe just the stick at
the Lyndon Johnson because I think he
was tired of being his vice president he
would have been on the ticket with Bobby
and that had you had a ticket that was
Bobby Kennedy and Hubert Humphrey going
up against richard nixon without the
taint of riots in chicago you will
remember that Hubert Humphrey came
within a whisker of beating Richard
Nixon and you will also remember that
there was nobody in America in 1968 who
understood Richard Nixon's
vulnerabilities better than the guy who
had run his brothers successful campaign
eight years before against richard nixon
and in his memoirs Nixon says that he
expected and feared that his opponent
would be Bobby Kennedy so I think not
just that Bobby Kennedy would have won
but he would have won with a kind of
coalition we talked about earlier of
whites and minorities and liberals and
conservatives and the least stretch of
all would have been that America would
have been a very different place not
just in 1968 but 50 years later if we
had dealt with issues like racial
intolerance 50 years before and hadn't
let them simmer for another 50 years and
it just it makes me when I think back
about that I want to say that Jack gave
me two great interviews for this book
and in one of the interviews we were we
were talking at the very stuffy
university club where tape recorders
aren't allowed and I discovered I had no
notepads to write down anything that he
was saying because I had brought my tape
recorder and I think the waiter told me
what are you doing with that and you
can't use that in our dining room so
Jack and I concocted a system where I
put the tape recorder under his napkin
and he ended up and I discovered how
well the tape recorder work because they
picked up everything he said and he was
a wonderful interview but I've never had
the experience I was a reporter for 20
years and I've been writing books for 15
years and I never had the experience
that I had with this Bobby Kennedy book
and anything that I've done before where
of the 400 people that I interviewed
easily half of them at some point during
the interview cried and they didn't cry
because I did anything especially mean
during the interview they cried because
even people who went on to become US
Attorney General or a very powerful US
senator remembered back to that time
with Bobby Kennedy as being one of the
most powerful senses that they were
working for something that mattered and
so guys like Nick katzenback and George
McGovern could look back and say that
their time with Bobby Kennedy was
something really profound and one of the
guys I can't remember whether he cried
or whether he made me want to cry but
one of the guys who told the most
touching stories was Jack Rosenthal
because I think that time in his life a
guy who went on to become the new york
times editorial page editor and if you
don't know in the world of journalism
there is nothing more sacred than being
the editor of the new york times
editorial page and a guy like that who
looked back at his days at number two in
a two-person office as being among the
most important things that he had ever
done that was saying something powerful
to me was that a period am i remembering
it wrong you remember exactly right and
let me tell you a little story that goes
along with that
it's the middle of may be early December
of 1963 Bobby has not been much in the
office but he comes in that day and he
he summons all of the assistant
attorneys general and the chief the
chief staff people so maybe 15 people
into his office at five o'clock and
what's this about and as we come in
where each handed a little gift wrapped
box inside it's a little blue Tiffany
leather box and inside our cufflinks
with the seal of the Department of
Justice engraved and on the back it says
RFK to jr. 1961 to 1963 and everybody
there got their own cufflinks and he had
harding anything to say except gratitude
for all of our support and then he
disappeared leaving us to think what's
this about is he leaving and you could
not resist the temptation to think these
things could not have been engraved just
since the assassination had to have been
the order had to go to to Tiffany for a
couple of engravers to do all this for
within a couple of weeks impossible so
it speculated they inspired the
speculation that had JFK not been
assassinated Bobby would have left the
department justice and the rumors would
have been right that Angie Novello his
secretary had been over to the State
Department measuring for drapes crates
what do you know about this um so I know
about it what people like you told me
about it and I think it's a great story
and I think that Bobby Kennedy probably
would have done left justice to do any
of a number of things
he not only had no respect for Dean Rusk
the Secretary of State he had supplanted
Dean Rusk as his brothers closest
advisor in terms of foreign policy
issues and I think that that Bobby was
qualified to do just about anything in
government and he could have there was a
rumor at one point that he'd be the CIA
director because during Operation
Mongoose he spent a lot of time at the
CIA and he was very powerful in the
intelligence community and thought we
needed somebody in the post Bay of Pigs
era somebody like him would have been
great eyes and ears in the intelligence
community he might have been state he
might have left he had them talked about
leaving and maybe doing something else
and going and teaching or spending more
time with his family um can I make a
suggestion that we pause for a second
and see whether to take some questions
before we your reception is starting in
in a bit and the the people have stories
or questions or anything that then
so the question was what Brandon workman
Brotherhood behind assassination so
every book talk I do I get questions
about the assassination every time I get
the same answer and the answer is that I
wish I could tell you that I knew what
had happened and that I could then tell
you true stories on what happened with
both Jack and Bobby's assassination lots
of people lots of very smart people it
raised lots of smart questions anybody
who couldn't provide answers has been
dead for a long time what I can't tell
you the only assassination story that I
want to tell you is what I think Bobby's
thought happened with Jax assassination
and what I think bombing worried it
happened was that in his time as
attorney general Bobby Kennedy stirred a
lot of Hornets nests he went after
organized crime in a way that no
attorney general before or since has
ever done he went after Jimmy Hoffa in a
way that he knew Jimmy Hoffa had a lot
of powerful friends and if he'd ever
wanted to do anything that he could have
stirred up a lot of trouble he went
after most of all Fidel Castro in a way
that he always worried given the obvious
Cuban connection with Lee Harvey Oswald
what had happened Jack at Bobby Kennedy
always used to say that it ought to have
been me and not jack and I think he had
a sense of guilt for the rest of his
life always wondering what really had
happened and was it something that he
had done and I think that he believed
the only way that we were really going
to know the answer to that question was
if Robert F Kennedy was president and
controlled the levers of investigative
powers his son Bobby jr. believes the
body would have reopened the
investigation of Jack's death and would
have come up with real answers it's all
speculation and it's certainly
speculation my pretending to know what
sense of guilt he felt and yet I totally
believe that and I think that's all I
could say about him that assassination I
could add a word about an investigative
reporter of great skill named Max
Holland whose name you probably know
because he wrote the book
telling who deep throat was he spent
much of his career investigating the JFK
assassination and he's come up with an
astonishingly persuasive and simple
explanation anybody who studied this
knows the parrot the puzzle of the third
bullet how could auswahl had possibly
fired three bullets in the time shown on
the Zapruder film for the cavalcade to
gone this far well it occurred to max
years later why is our imagination or
our knowledge limited to what Zapruder
happened cat catch on his film so he
investigated and discovered that the
Zapruder film in fact has two parts and
the fruiterer later confirmed that he
was unsure how much film he had left in
his camera so he took pictures of the
cars as he came around the corner and
then stopped until they got closer to
him and he turned it on again and
there's like 12 seconds or so in between
and if you add those seconds to the time
that Oswald was there poised in the
School Book Depository there was easily
enough time for him to fired three shots
so no mystery and he didn't have to be a
man on the grassy knoll or some
conspiracy Oswald quit well he goes on
and what happened to the third bullet
they know that the first bullet hit JFK
in the head the second bullet went
through him and through John Connolly's
thigh and hand and that wasn't so much
magic you could do that the arithmetic
and figure out the geometry of that but
what happened to the third bullet and
people heard three bullets and there are
three bullets on the motorcycle radio
tapes well he finally figured out
that between Oswald in this sixth floor
window and the passing limousine there
was a streetlight and a tree and you
could more or less see through the tree
and his theory was he must have shot oh
sorry there's none of the fact there was
a big chip in the curb of the highway
about 30 or 40 feet down the street
which was unexplained what Holland
figured out was Oswald fired the third
shot it was the first shot he fired
through the trees and the bullet must
have hit the light post how do you prove
that he got somehow got the city to let
him get a high rise lift and they
inspected the light post no good because
the light post had been replaced 10 or
15 years ago so he dogged Lee he said
well what happened to the old light post
well it was in the city trash yard and
they tracked it down and they found in
exactly the right place on the arm of
the light post a dent did it get made by
a bullet nobody knows but it's sure
plausible anyway the the fact is as
Larry said nobody will ever know the
exact answers but that's a pretty good
one oh boy
my best friend
No
okay can we move on to other people's
questions the man yeah
the legacy that was having in
contemporary politics is after is that
word into successful years
so I think his legacy were seeing his
legacy every day if you would have asked
the why am I blanking on the Eric Holder
the Attorney General who his role model
was he was quite explicit it was Bobby
Kennedy's Attorney General if you asked
Barack Obama who his role model was it
was Bobby Kennedy more than probably
anybody in the Democratic Party forever
if you were to ask Hillary Clinton Bill
Clinton's role model was JFK Hillary
Clinton's role model is RFK I think he
continues whether or not they are
matching the standards the high
standards he said is another question
but he inspires because he died at this
moment of extraordinary hope a way to
make all of you feel old or make me feel
old is to recognize that last November
Bobby Kennedy would have turned 90 but
to all of us the picture in the front of
my book of Bobby Kennedy at age 42 is
the image we will always carry that was
Bobby Kennedy he died before he had a
chance to do things but he was on the
cusp of I think doing something much
more inspired than his brother Jack I
want to say one quick thing about the
contrast between Jack and Bobby is a way
of answering that Jack Kennedy anytime
he was asked anything controversial
during his presidency when are you going
to fire J Edgar Hoover when are you
going to give us a hard a really tough
civil rights bill when are you going to
take the advisors out of Vietnam it was
always when I am reelected in 1964 I'll
take on these really politically
difficult issues Bobby Kennedy lacked
Jack's patience I think he had three
times more passion if you were elected
had he been elected president he would
have tried to do all those tough things
in the first five minutes of his
presidency because they were different
people in thee I had a couple of points
to that nobody realizes this but Robert
Kennedy was responsible for major
criminal justice reforms
have been lasting in 1962 he sponsored a
national bail conference organized by
herb stirrers the idea was all over the
country people who are using money bail
as punishment when the only legitimate
purpose for bail is to guarantee repays
reappearance for trial I think we ought
to be given credit for the achievements
many of the achievements of his children
and probably most of all because of what
he did in civil rights I think he won
not just for his own legacy but for the
Democratic Party the trust of the black
community in the system
very slow civil right
so I think it's a legitimate criticism
but like everything it depends what
moment you're talking about at the
beginning of the Kennedy administration
and Bobby Kennedy's most profound role
and Jack may disagree i think in civil
rights was in a way trying to slow down
a lot of things in the civil rights
movement he believed that we ought to be
doing a lot of litigation in terms of
getting voting rights litigated case by
case he believed in having he
substantially increased a number of
people in the Civil Rights Division at
the Justice Department but he wanted
things like the Freedom Rides people
remember the Freedom Rides when young
blacks and whites went across the south
in segregated and bus terminals and
segregated buses and put their own
bodies on the line to integrate
interstate transportation and Bobby
Kennedy essentially wanted to slow that
down because he knew Jack Kennedy was
about to have an important summit with
Nikita Khrushchev and he didn't want
America embarrassed in the eyes of the
world in terms of having this violence
in places like Birmingham and aniston
and Montgomery and in those early days
and what I call his sort of clueless
period on civil rights there was one
person in the civil rights movement who
understood just how good Bobby Kennedy
could be and that was Martin Luther King
jr. and he said he told his young
acolytes who fifty years later repeated
to me people like Andy young and Jesse
Jackson martin luther king told them
there is within Bobby Kennedy good and
it is up to us to recognize that good
and pull it out of him and ironically
the best expression of just how good he
would become on civil rights was the
evening of Martin Luther King's death
and what he did magically in
Indianapolis and so it was like so many
of his learning curves started out not
knowing much and ended up in the words
of or in the expression of Burke
Marshall the head of his his assistant
attorney general for civil rights whose
daughter was at my talk last night when
Burke Marshall was asked how much did
Bobby grow on civil rights he started
raising his arm up here and it wouldn't
go high enough and that's what he did
let me add a practical word it's very
easy to be moralistic in retrospect but
when Robert Kennedy became Attorney
General the chairman of the most
important congressional committee that
the Justice Department had to deal with
on a daily basis was a James Eastland of
Mississippi and he wanted his college
roommate William Harold Cox to be
appointed a federal judge in Mississippi
two things to say about that one is it
was and is senatorial courtesy to give
the senior senator from the state the
deference to appoint their nominees so
that would have been true even if you'd
been from Montana but as Eastland who is
from sunflower County a hated center of
racism if you had to do business with
him every day and yes the Kennedys
acquiesced in making William Errol Cox
the federal judge from the Southern
District of Mississippi was also true is
that they appointed a series of brave
judges who stood up for civil rights in
the south calm and the fact that RFK
chose Burke Marshall to be the head of
the Civil Rights Division anybody who
knows about Burke or what the Civil
Rights Division did the idea of doing
case-by-case litigation was all that it
was let it was politically possible to
do for at least a couple or three years
until the churches all over the country
young people all over the country
Freedom Summer and so on finally forced
the enactment of the Civil Rights Act of
1964 and finally the Voting Rights Act
of 1965 which was the culmination of
all those individual cases you look into
the uneasy relationship between the
Kennedy brothers and Adlai Stevenson
which I figured extend back to nineteen
fifty-six when President Democratic
presidential candidate Adlai Stevenson
selected for father he is running
Kennedy and then of course we know that
Stevenson was served the Kennedy
administration is currently represented
speech at the end here to cancel
the time of the
miss Eliza the hell we looked into the
relationship with rivalry between
Stevenson Academy yes the so yes and I
talked to Stevenson son who was the
former senator from Illinois who talked
about how his father not only really
despised Bobby what was really
interesting is that lots of people
blamed Bobby for things that Jack was
equally responsible for Lyndon Johnson
always blamed Bobby for his being left
out of things during the Kennedy
administration when I'm convinced that
he would never have been left out unless
Jack wanted it to be but it was easier
for Johnson to say it was Bobby
Kennedy's fault than to say the
president didn't like me and I think
Stevenson also blame Bobby for a lot of
that stuff when in fact it was both
brothers who thought that he was a
weak-kneed he was a liberal in all the
ways that they hated liberals and he
lost you lost twice it wasn't that he
didn't he did Jack Kennedy the biggest
favor of the delegates did Jack Ben
Kennedy the biggest failure they could
have ever done for him by not making him
the vice presidential nominee with a
ticket that went down to such a
devastating defeat in 1956 there were
rumors and unconvinced that they're
apocryphal but there were rumors of Joe
Kennedy helped engineer Jack's loss in
1956 because he thought it was such a
horrible move for him to be running for
vice president but they really dislike
one another and they both blame
Stevenson for a lot of the problems
during the missile crisis in the early
days with American not standing strong
in the United Nations when in fact
Stevenson helped behind-the-scenes
engineer a lot of the things that Jack
was talking about before the exchange of
missiles and I think Adlai Stevenson was
like Lyndon Johnson a lost opportunity
he was somebody who represented a lot of
important ideas
an important constituency in the
Democratic Party and had the Kennedys
been more broad-minded and secure they
should have figured out a real role for
him and should have recognized he was a
good guy kind of personal footnote about
anti stevenson when I was a Harvard
freshman barely out of high school the
Crimson sent me to a stakeout Stevenson
son's house in Cambridge because the
presidential candidate was coming to
visit his son and so there i sat outside
with a shivering in my thin overcoat for
an hour or so and finally Adly came out
and he was you must be cold come in so
he and the theft and a photographer came
inside and he said I've got five minutes
so there's a fit you know my albums a
picture me taking notes and then I
followed him to MIT where he gave a
lecture where he said famously via ova
capital Dora essed or for the engineers
among you the way of the egghead is hard
so let me get one last quick thing on
Stephenson Bobby Kennedy hang on hang
out in that 56 campaign with Stevenson
supposedly working for Stephenson and
what he was actually doing was figuring
out everything that a candidate could do
wrong which is what Stephenson he felt
was doing and made sure that his brother
Jack wouldn't do those same things four
years later bobby was as hard-nosed a
political campaign operative as there
ever was in Richard Nixon who we know
was stuck with a nickname Tricky Dick
said he learned his best tricks from
Bobby in 1960
now she loves Stevenson and had no
fondness and especially for Bobby Larry
one aspect we haven't covered at all is
our F K's sense of humor hmm so his
sense of humor was extraordinary can I
just say one more thing about the
difference between Jack Kennedy and
Bobby Kennedy we all know that the
Kennedy Patriot gel Kennedy dreamed that
in succession each of his sons would
become president it would start in his
ideal world it would have started with
Joe Jr and then Jack and then Bobby and
then of course baby Ted and the Rose
Kennedy who we will remember as the
matriarch who died at 301 praying in
church the had a much simpler dream for
her sons and that was that one of them
would become a priest and I'm convinced
had Jack Kennedy been a priest he would
have been the Pope because that was who
Jack Kennedy was he was about things and
intellectual whatever had Bobby Kennedy
been a priest he would have been a
parish priest because that's who he was
and the way he learned he learned by
being down on the grass roots he learned
by experiencing things and I don't know
about you and as a Jew I have no right
talking about what kind of priest is
what but I would much rather have had as
my president the parish priest who was
down there at the grassroots and he had
an extraordinary sense of humor and his
sense of humor I'm trying to think of
any particular example but his sense of
humor was when Jack Kennedy named him to
be attorney General Jack talked about
the fact he goes outside of his
Georgetown house and every day he'd have
pressed sessions and he say these are
the cabinet people I'm appointing now
and he said my temptation was to come
out in the middle of the night and
scream when nobody's around Bobby's the
Attorney General and he went on to say I
named him as Attorney General to give my
younger brother some legal experience
Bobby who had never tried a case of law
case in the court of law and Bobby came
back and said you know that was mean
stuff you said and Jack said I was just
kidding it was you know I was making fun
and he said but you were doing all of it
I was the butt of the joke and it was
your great joke but why did you make me
the bat and the
Bobby Kennedy other than with Jack had a
quip he could never get away with it
because Jack was the older brother and
he couldn't come back and do anything
other than complain but he would in
church when he would take his young
staffers to church with him and they
people would come around with a
collection plate and the Kennedys
famously never had any money they never
had any money for tips and they never
had any money for the collection plate
and so his staffers knew that they were
supposed to give some money and they put
in a five-dollar bill which was a lot of
money in those days and Bobby said I'm
not that cheap and he would always tell
them he was going to pay them back when
it was buying one she will put it in the
collection plate and he never paid one
of them back up any you know I had the
same experience any time you were in a
car with him or cab or somewhere you had
to have money because he never did and
but you learn not to resent that because
for example when I got married he and
his wife gave me this extraordinarily
beautiful Steuben glass tray which way
beyond anything we might have expected
there's one one humorous moment in a
very tense time when at Ole Miss when
the rioting took place at the effort to
introduce james Meredith the first black
to the University of Mississippi and the
US Marshals and Nick hasten back and
head Guffman and others were trapped
inside the Lyceum building and there
were bombs and shooting going on around
a French journalist had just been killed
and Nick the army was somehow for all of
its vaunted Signal Corps capacity was
unable to get a line to the White House
well Nick got through to the White House
and the general said how did you do that
and mix it well you see you take this
time and you live and they kept it he
called national 8 14 14 and they kept
the line open all day and at some point
Nick said what when some of the marshals
were wounded by gunshots
the next said to Bobby in Washington
people are saying it's beginning to feel
like the Alamo Kennedy said well you
know what happened to those folks great
so my guess is this would be a great
time to get before we do that can I just
say one thing I'm am NOT an expert in
many things but the one thing having
written a previous book and donated my
papers here on am an earlier hero of
mine named Superman I would like to just
say that then my clever in here tonight
is my vision of Superman and I would
like to just if you wouldn't mind this
is a this any newspapers if you were
still at a newspaper this is we're so
much less than even the New York Times
standard of what you can accept his
grasp we just get a hear you out